bill maher claims trump could win so
easy because of drag queens
but he can't let go of the election this
is a mediated story comic component bill
maher claimed that the former president
trump could win easy because of drag
queens but can't let go of elections on
friday night edition of hbo's real time
with bill maher the host uh
uh took a table bit about future
headlines that included libraries in
texas to offer impotent gun nut story
hour to banter with guests andrew
sullivan and katie herzog about what a
drag culture issues like a drag queen
story hour are on democrats mar
explained that poor trump could easily
win if he could let go to 2020 because
of the drag queens do you agree with
them i'm a little upset with bill first
of all because he had me on
maligned me as a russian spy now he
himself admits there was no russian
collusion but he won't have me back on
you know why i'm way funnier than he is
way farther you think you're funny
you're the one when you're easy roger no
no when you go to bill maher's show they
take you in your dressing room
and his producer comes and says well
great to have you please give me one
favor don't try to be funnier than bill
i said bill's got an entire you know
group of writers cranking out of stuff
yeah i'm all by myself they ask you to
do that oh yeah absolutely no look i've
been on bill's show several times yeah
and it's always lively and he's
entertaining it's not the drag queens of
the reason trump can win it's gas prices
food shortages
inflation leaving several billion
dollars worth of equipment in
afghanistan shipping 40 billion dollars
off to ukraine when we can't spend the
money to uh seal our own border those
are the reasons that he can win
the the 2020 election is kind of tricky
it would be false to say that people are
not concerned about it that doesn't mean
it's going to get undone or redone or
that's not realistic
but but
voter integrity the integrity of the
roles that's a legitimate issue
and i don't think trump can stop talking
about it in that sense do you think he
should uh in terms of the fact that our
next election needs to be honest fair
and transparent yes absolutely no do you
think he should stop bringing up that
there was fraud in the last election do
you think you need you need to just move
on and focus on today's issues it's the
precursor to insisting that there be no
fraud in the next election so i don't
think i don't think it should be the
raison and detroit to his candidacy
because politics is not is never about
the past it's always about the future
let me ask you a question on bill maher
because i watch his show religiously or
you know you might say religiously or
whatever his uh you know thing is but
when you sit down with him you're not on
the panel typically with the last time i
saw you did the one on one yes the sort
of like the pre-game to the show yes and
it's really almost like
i don't want to say an interrogation but
he's he's coming right at you and
whatever your talking points are he's
going to dismiss them and
get to his point so sitting down with
bill maher
you must have seen how he's sort of
what does he famously say these days uh
pat i haven't changed the democratic
party has changed they've moved a little
bit far left uh what have you seen him
uh
update his opinions what what what's
your take on bill maher these days
because a lot of people
are basically saying hey you know what
this bill maher i never really agreed
with him
it's kind of making sense these days are
you starting to see more of that on some
issues i think he's been very consistent
and i agree with him so for example he's
always been a critic of radical muslim
he's always been critical of islamic
terrorism he's always been pro-cannabis
legalization position i've held for 30
years he's smoking his joints on the
regular as a as a libertarian um i do
think that he has come around on the
hypocrisy of the american left so yeah a
lot of my conservative friends are like
have a new appreciation for bill maher
do you uh yeah i do i think he's been i
think he's being honest
why won't he have you back home uh
because he didn't want to get bested
again oh you think so
any time i think bill maher can handle
you though at any time
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]